[Applause]
very good very good oh
oh
i've been oh for a moment to wear this
tonight i bought it today and you know
they don't come in men's sizes
they actually do they're available at
any decent store in manchester
now have you got obviously you're a fan
of the one direction i can see but as
one direction met ian mckellen new
zealand
what one direction before i thought
you'd have a bigger beard yeah yeah yeah
but didn't you come close to meeting in
new zealand yeah we were on tour in um
new zealand and they were filming yes
and you were meant to come and see us
filming
the day after your final concert so i
thought i'd go and have a look at them
see who they are yeah very enjoyable
thank you
he's a wizard so i think he wins it was
a very small show i mean it was just you
no
no fireworks or anything but and quite a
small theater do you remember
back in the day anyway they didn't turn
up the next day to visit us because why
i don't know why
what what had happened on your last
night um i think
i don't know what i don't think i don't
i mean maybe we're on the water tonight
though yeah we're safe yeah
your plane might have been moved early
or something yeah
now ian mcgowan looks i saw the pictures
of of you all at the premiere on monday
night oh yeah
and i mean it's been part of your life
for night on 14 years
now so it must was that an emotional
night or were
the emotions happened already yeah well
it's over you know we're not not
we've not been working on the hobbit for
some time now but i it was very moving i
mean you go and these kids have been
sleeping out all night what do you know
about this but the
the the the living
we're all homeless these
uh people were not born when we started
making
uh lord of the rings you know so it's
it's a big part of their lives and
that's
that's very very sweet isn't it and
they'll be able to see all six movies
now and show them to their kids
that's what's nice we've made classics
that's lovely and also
it will take nearly a day to watch it
but it can be done have you have you
done it yeah i think i did i was off
school
ill once i think i did on with my friend
i think we watched them
[Applause]
because we go to glamorous things too
only recently we were at a bbc
party we showed that glass of wine it
was fun
between us and we met that lovely lady
oh i'm surprised you're bringing that
lady up are we allowed to bring that
lady up well you tell me it's your show
well i don't know
but it happened to you not me so you
tell them
what what bit of okay okay so this this
lady came up to us
we're at a bbc party she came up to the
tour we were chatting sharing our wine
straws and uh she went i do disability
at the bbc
whatever that means and then she looked
at him
and what did she say to you well she
said that i qualify
and it was a hype thing not good
what a charmer do you know since since
we had that meeting when the lady told
me that i was
technically as far as the bbc's
concerned disabled
i've had a member of a council i won't
know where tell me
that i could get a parking badge
the rest of the couch is so jealous
right now
parking pads thanks for that
i won't forget the day that ryan gosling
high-fived meekers
because i'm officially disabled
you've been 50 before yes of course i'm
a huge fan
okay okay okay if i if i if i had to
force you julie if i could force you
julie
what would you say is your favorite 50
cent record of all time okay
well love the first album get rich
yeah get rich die trying good absolutely
loved massacre yeah yeah my favorite
is in the club
yeah very good
i didn't know you knew it no i'll say oh
right i got
you know shot nine times but it was one
time
so and i just didn't see the person
coming or i would have avoided it
you know this happened and and i was
trying to write a song
conceptually that would define more of
who i am so i wrote
nine shots and just picked nine painful
moments that i experienced in my life
and used the shot as a metaphor but the
night
where were you shot where like in front
of my grandmother's house
but where on your body
most of them in the legs like i hit my
hand and i hit in the face
so like the uh fragment portion of it is
in my tongue so it kind of changed the
way
i speak a little bit like and you're
wrapping as well what is it still in
your tongue can you see it yeah it's
great for oral sex
[Applause]
[Music]
let me just make a note of that uh yeah
i'm a better man now but is it like a
lump can you see it
yeah let's have a feel 50.
i've washed my hands makes her old sex
and then you're gonna put your finger in
my mouth
hey i better not add ourselves let's go
have a look have a look see if you can
just
look they're still hermetically sealed
thank you very much there they go
wow how would you prepare did someone
tell you to come with this
how did that happen what's the odds of
that you'd be sitting in the front row
with this
who does this kind of stuff right it
only happens on this program honestly
oh yeah i can feel it
wake up tomorrow night after the show
they'll be worth a lot yeah
the last episode she was promoting a
film she didn't know who she was playing
in the film
it was finished it was in the cinema
yeah it was a long time after we'd
filmed it
you might have checked before you came
on a chat show
[Music]
i have no idea
i don't know why this they also because
contractually no offense but we're sort
of asked to come
all right wow
but i do wonder why they asked me to do
it
i don't help do it
i assume thinking she's never been in
one of my phones
she's good i
like her
this is a weird kind of almost like a
link to bumblebee because when
uh you were starting off in wrestling
you had a persona
that am i right we're sort of half man
half machine was that
that's correct yes this was prototype it
was awful
yeah so you uh you want to try to find a
persona or here's some more inside
baseball for a gimmick
where is it describes you as a character
so like when you walk out people notice
you
and they kind of you can describe your
character but these are not gimmicks
these this is
real well whoa i mean if they work
yes but you kind of it's it's a trial
and error process with a lot of errors
and uh and my first try was uh the
prototype which was half man
and half machine and 100 crap
but given that you're not half a machine
how did you demonstrate
you were a machine well i i used this
ability to talk rather monotone
and would say things authoritative and
just when i said i would kick your ass
at the fairgrounds on sunday i would
rewind it and say it again for you right
they say i would kick your ass at the
fairgrounds
that didn't work you
know oh it didn't that's
a good one anybody but you worked on one
i have one yeah
you found huge success as john
cena imagine that i figure i need to
come up with some sort of name
yeah look everyone doesn't every every
wrestler has a name yes and people think
that like hey man how'd you make up the
name john cena
i was like no dude i would have made up
like dick hammer bush or something cool
like that
or something i don't know that's a star
from there no one's letting you go out
with that
but uh they actually think that john
cena is a gimmick name but no that's
actually through all the the
presentation that is wwe
i'm stuck with are you wrestling around
jimmy i used to love wrestling
uh when we were much younger about the
same time as transformers back in the
day we had big daddy
yep the giant haystack
uh no i used to love it i thought it was
just fantastic by the way i'm john cena
there's all these awesome names you know
the ultimate drooler
or like nothing and like to have uh
signature moves and things and one of
yours is the
you can't see me but that's correct is
that true that came out of your family
somehow yeah i was i was dared to do it
so i was actually making the music
for my own theme song that you just so
heard and finally serenaded me too thank
you very much
uh and we played it for my brother and
the first time he heard it this was uh
the
the 50 cents crew had a really popular
song called in the club
and he heard it the first time and
instead of dancing like he was our
litmus test to see what songs were good
what songs are bad
he did this oh my gosh
and i'm like dude what are you doing
it's like no everybody does this man
everybody does this
and i guess this is from 50 cent's video
and he's like
you won't do it on tv so what the hell
do i got to lose am i going to fire me
of course i'll do it on tv
but instead of doing this i did this
and now for 15 years
because of a dare i've been doing this
and i'll do you one better people
actually think i'm invisible there would
be people
to look at this couch and be like why is
there nobody next to mcconaughey
john cena would be there but we can't
see him
so you never know you remember hacksaw
jim douglas and
king kong bundy scandal bars and caravan
eriksen carry the
and go i got kicked out of perspective
i'm talking texas wrestling i get kicked
out of her i see him in shreveport
for pelting skandarak bar with a bag of
tomatoes
on the eighth road skandar akbar was a
man dressed as a sheik that used to
throw fire
yes and he managed king kong bundy who
was like 484 pounds
remember the missing parts unknown and
uh
the green face spit green mystic they
sound really good good stuff
entertaining it was so much fun and i'm
john cena okay
you